[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite here in Park City and I'm
sitting down with the team behind dinner
in America okay we've got Pat Healy Lea
Thompson Kyle gone there Emily Skaggs
and director writer director Adam Carter
ray Meyer thanks guys for coming in
thanks Sam
chance to see this yet what is it about
wow this is a friend should we do it no
we do it no I think we forgot it
I know go for it renegade love story
about two misfits who find each other
and themselves through music it's all
original songs I read during this movie
huh yeah correct correct there was music
constructed for the film itself so that
we did that ahead of production in
pre-production
like when they when the kids got out
there yeah yeah yeah we all are
Emily - Emily did - Adam and I
collaborated and wrote a song together
for the movie yeah so can you explain
the genesis of this project where did
this come from am because you've been
making movies for a while mm-hmm so this
came out of two separate sketches that
did weren't going anywhere
and basically merged them together so
there was a story about Simon as a
guinea pig like basically selling his
body to the science for money to pay for
making punk rock records and then there
was another story I was working on about
the shark family and it was just it was
just that it was called dinner in
America and it was just setting up the
family it was just it was like
situational dinner stuff I was just
write it you know just sketching stuff
out and both weren't going anywhere
so I merged them together and then it
started picking up a lot of you know
attraction and I was getting interested
in it so so this wasn't based on a short
film no a lot of you guys have already
been at Sundance you guys you guys are
returnees what does it mean to return to
this festival how special is it for you
start with you well I've been coming
here now for 21 years I've been here six
separate times yeah I came here in 1999
I came here in 2001 as a director of a
short which was incredible because you
know I guess I'm technically an alumni
and and you know it's always special
especially that first night screening
unless people don't like it in which
cases no nobody throws stuff at you but
you just geek just kind of get out of
there but this was that this lot tonight
or last night the premiere was explosive
I mean it was like incredible it's like
a rock concert yeah I remember that
first premiere for a compliance well
that was for compliance was a whole
other thing because we thought we were
gonna get killed or hurt by somebody we
were actually ushered by security into
an elevator like you know like after the
Robert Kennedy assassination it was
really like people were yelling you know
we were rapists and things and it was
that was really unexpected this is
unexpected in a different way because
it's it's it is intense and in-your-face
but it's it's it's funny and it's a joy
and it's ultimately you know a you know
just you know very cathartic for people
in a way that that movie isn't so for me
it's just I mean I don't know made me
feel a lot younger again you know like
last night it's like I've been telling
them that it's a lot like the movies
that you know that I love the cult
movies I love like you know like
reprimanding swirl which I was in it
like things like that that that I don't
know but nobody makes those movies
anymore and nobody is making movies like
Adam has which is just like you know I
don't care if people aren't doing this
or you're not supposed to do this like
people get on board with it it's
exciting so that's thumper always like
fun here because it's always the first
time you're seeing it and Leah what's
your history with the festival like I've
been here a few times and at with movies
and then a few times just as kind of a
tourist because I really love the whole
independent scene and I love I I
personally love the idea and
like this movie is what's so wonderful
about an independent film a small movie
like this is that it's it's Adams vision
it's one person's vision I did a lot of
really big movies that were a lot of
people's vision and you can see how the
scripts get watered down and you have no
idea what what the original intention
was and so for me I've made a few films
like this that I just love because I
feel even directed my own movie that
called the ever spectacular men where it
was my you know the the writers vision
and you really I got to do it all myself
you know and I like being part of that
and when I read the script I just
thought it was so great and you know
even though my parts looked very big I
was just like please let me be a part of
this well where do you fit into this I
just make out with Kyle basically sweet
Dan and John Ford Coley jammed to on I
was already a fan you know like get to
go to Detroit and make out with Kyle
yeah I was into and Emily you're coming
back to sunny ins after winning the
festival a couple years ago with
so it's super exciting this movie is
incredibly special to me because of the
relationships that we built together the
Patty and Simon relationship is just
it's incredibly special we really poured
a lot of ourselves into the characters
and we're really vulnerable to go to
those places and so I'm very protective
of them and also so excited to see
people responding so positively to them
and and seeing themselves in the
characters it's really it's heartening
and it's why I do this so and what other
misfit comedy sort of inspired you or
they you look towards right for
inspiration there you know there's stuff
like welcome to the dollhouse I think
that feels like it's in this space you
know Napoleon Dynamite like outsiders
but yeah but I wouldn't say they were
really direct I think really it came
down to writing things that weren't
going anywhere and just having like a
lot of marination over a long period of
time while we're talking I think I
sketched the Kix thing in 2006 so so
that's you know that's about 14 years
ago when I when I put a seed out there
and then I think the dinner in America
one was maybe 2009 or so
and then I didn't even connect them
until maybe what would two thousand
thirteen or fourteen somewhere in there
my buddy Ross Putnam produced this film
a lot there were a lot of producers but
Ben Stiller was another one I was
curious how Ben and his partner Nick
Nikki like how instrumental were they in
getting this made they they were so
helpful like just you know opening a lot
of doors for us and like just you know
just in guidance to spirit spirit
animals like just amazing like the
support there with Nicky and Ben has
just been great through this whole
process Nicky was on set for like the
entire film so it you know at just just
having him there with his experience
like it was just it was awesome that I
can't thank them enough for making this
happen since this is about a girl who
runs off with the lead singer of her
favorite band on I'm curious who who is
you know who are your favorite bands and
would you protect the lead singer of
that band if the cops were after them
one of a big inspiration for me and this
movie is Ezra Furman I don't know if you
know Ezra Furman they're incredible
they're sort of a part of this new queer
pop punk culture and I've always loved
them and I would take a bullet for Ezra
Furman okay who's a favorite band and
would you protect that the singer of
that man favorite band
I like this dude jayati walleston I yeah
I guess I'd let him hide out in my house
for for a week right now he's my
favorite lead of a band so I would
definitely protect y'all I've already
expressed my love for that England Dan &
John Ford Coley yes yes that's pretty
good
an MV of a favorite I mean if Joey
Ramone was alive I took a bullet for him
hundred percent yes see for me it'd be
Axl
Oh Axl wasn't trouble he could count on
me I think he is in trouble he's in
trouble
I saw in in the in the credits that this
film was in memory of Danny laner yeah
cleaner line I forget but he's one of my
very first interviews great guy did the
obituary for him why why dedicated to
him what is your connection to Danny
okay so Danny Danny was one of the first
producers with Ross that came on I can
tell you a little anecdote here but
Danny was very interested in directing
this film for himself and was kind of
working an angle you know at first no
and Danny for those who don't know is
the director of Harold & Kumar Go to
White yes yes and that dude where's my
car so yeah Danny was working a little
bit of an angle to try and get it in the
beginning but what but when he met with
me he he knew that I had a vision for it
so he wanted to you know sort of spirit
animal and shepherd this thing with Ross
and Dave who came onto they were the
first originally option to Ross Dave and
Danny that's it and that's how this all
started so yeah so Danny was great we
did it we did I did
pass based on notes that they had and
you know I'm just thinking back on on it
without Danny but uh he he remained
instrumental in the first year or so and
as we as we got into this and then then
he got sick he got cancer and uh you
know by the end of production we lost
Danny well he was a great guy it was
very classy move you today I want to add
to that when I came here I mentioned I
came here with my short film mullet in
2001 one of the few people that reached
out to me and I didn't know him was
Danny and he just loved the movie and
wanted to help me you know write a
script and work with me on a lot of
things and we remained friends until he
passed away he was he was a great guy
and he was that that kind of person that
that got behind a lot of people even
though you know he did you work on his
own career too he if he believed in you
and I could think of a half-dozen other
people he really was there for you and
really helped you creatively but just
support it you know if you had a unique
vision that he liked and it was funny
and interesting to him he he was really
great champion he gave me he gave me I
think was one of my very first one I
went to the student reporter and I
always appreciated it
Liat a couple questions for you you
played Marmee in an adaptation of Little
Women a couple of years ago have you
seen the the Gregor wick film yes I have
what what are your what was your take on
it yeah you think you could win any
Oscars next month yeah I mean yeah yeah
I I thought it was really good my movie
was not as good for sure but it was
interesting because they both did the
same thing the little women I did we
shot here and a friend of mine was
producing it and they went back and
forth and time in the exact same way
which was really interesting no one had
ever done it
and so kudos to the screenwriter of the
first little yeah because they had the
same idea to like mix the books and go
back and forward in time but yeah okay I
was just curious for your take on that
one and then I know you also directed an
episode of star girl right yes what can
we expect from from that show oh my god
it was so fun like the greatest stunt
girls ever I got to work with on wires
it was the stunts sequences are amazing
and I got to design he's really cool
stunt sequences when are we gonna get a
chance to see you it's a I think it's
premiering next month or two months from
now
yeah guys thank you so much for coming
in the team behind dinner in America
thank you the Kia separ sweet for
sponsoring this as well good job thank
you